[Música]
con nuestra segunda invitada el día
vamos a hablar de la guerra en Ucrania
vamos a hacer también un pequeño balance
de lo que ha ocurrido estas últimas
semanas y sobre todo en la ciudad de
gerson recientemente Pues liberada por
los ucranianos las tropas ucranianas que
replegaron a las tropas rusas que sin
embargos tanto había en la periferia de
esta ciudad pero pues ya liberaron esta
ciudad de gersona la segunda más
importante de ese país y prácticamente
capturadas el inicio de esta guerra en
Ucrania allí precisamente se encuentra
nuestra enviada especial Catalina Gómez
Ángel a esta ciudad ucraniana de gerson
Catalina la salud de un gusto saludarle
y que nos acompañe en este programa
matinal de nuestro canal directo América
le pregunto primeramente de esta
situación de la ciudad tras La retirada
de los rusos también evidentemente los
dos cuartos de tortura denunciados por
las autoridades ucranianas que se han
encontrado en esta ciudad
Raúl muy buenos días para ustedes la
situación en la ciudad es cada vez más
complicada primero por la
infraestructura la falta de Electricidad
la falta de agua hace que la vida sea
cada vez más difícil ahora que hace
muchísimo más frío estamos por lo menos
a 0 grados estamos aquí al frente de la
estación de tren de gerson y adentro hay
muchísima gente tratando de cargar sus
móviles o sus linternas allí porque son
los únicos lugares donde hay
electricidad Pero también a esta hora
vemos mucha gente llegando tratando de
tomar ese único tren que sale
diariamente hacia la Ciudad de kiev Y es
que los ataques contra la ciudad se han
intensificado también en los últimos
días desde ayer saben cada vez más
frecuentes misiles artillería los rusos
no están lejos de aquí están al otro
lado del Río A menos de un kilómetro y
los habitantes de gerson dicen que nunca
habían visto paradójicamente la guerra
tan cerca y tienen mucho miedo porque
los rusos realmente atacan
indiscriminadamente todos los sectores
de la ciudad Así que la situación en
gerson es complicada cada día más y con
el frío pues peor claro es complicada
Catalina usted nos dio una provoca para
ir entonces pues ampliando Punto por
punto hablando del frío de este duro
invierno y con los ataques constantes
rusos a la infraestructura energética
ucraniana Cuál es la situación
actualmente tanto de gestión de gerson
como en el resto del país Catalina Cómo
se están preparando las personas de Cara
a este Euro invierno lo acabas de decir
0 grados en este momento y todavía falta
mucho para que se desarrolle esta
temporada invernal
y estamos en una de las ciudades menos
frías de todo de Ucrania imagínense Raúl
como podría hacer esto nosotros entramos
a Ucrania por el occidente pasamos por
la ciudad de leopolis y recorrimos hasta
el centro del país durante el fin de
semana y estaba nevando todo un
recorrido ya aquí en esta parte del sur
no nieva pero si hace muchísimo frío y
está lloviendo no solamente aquí sino la
ciudad de Nicolás donde también hay
problemas de infraestructura donde
tampoco hay electricidad y donde tampoco
hay agua así que ya lo han advertido las
autoridades no solamente las autoridades
ucranianas sino de las Naciones Unidas
de que esto puede ser un invierno muy
duro donde puede llegar a morir gente
por causa de del Invierno la gente está
tratando de prepararse con con leña los
que tienen calefacción de leña en
algunas casas hay gas pero mucha gente
tiene calefacción con energía eléctrica
entonces imagínense lo que puede llegar
a hacer esta situación incluso también
Catalina frente al invierno la
Organización Mundial de la Salud dijo
que esta temporada invernada en Ucrania
era una cuestión de supervivencia por
precisamente eso no contar con los
recursos necesarios o para mantenerse
caliente para mantenerse a salvo o
Catalina también eh toquemoso otro tema
importante no de los habitantes de
gerson El trauma que han vivido estos
habitantes cuando esta ciudad estaba
capturada por las tropas rusas ahora se
retiraron Pero por supuesto que quedan
todas estas secuelas todas estas heridas
emocionales que también la guerra trae
consigo no sé si también ha tenido la
oportunidad de hablar con algunos de
familiares de los desaparecidos de
personas que han sido torturadas no
si Raúl hemos estado hablando todo el
mundo realmente quiere contar su
historia hemos por ejemplo allá nos
encontrábamos con una mujer que su
hermano está desaparecido él le hacía
parte de los de las fuerzas
territoriales la defensa territorial que
son estos grupos de personas que se
unieron apoyar al ejército durante al
comienzo de la guerra y cuando ellos
tomaron jerson ella sabe que su hermano
estuvo herido fue a un hospital y
realmente desapareció no sabe cuál es su
paradero y teme por ejemplo que esté que
sea uno de los prisioneros que tiene
Rusia pero ella no tiene ninguna
información de ella Ella decía que a
pesar de las dificultades no se quedaría
aquí en ningún momento pero los traumas
también son muy grandes en los niños
Raúl los niños tenían mucho miedo no
solamente que sus padres fueran a ser
desaparecidos por los rusos sino también
por los ataques los niños cada vez que
oyen una artillería de estas que estamos
oyendo todo el tiempo pues
tiemblan por eso muchos de esos niños
sus están sacando en este momento de la
ciudad porque ya no pueden con el trauma
que tienen claro Catalina usted también
estuvo en Ucrania prácticamente desde el
inicio de esta invasión luego se regresó
a su base Irán y está regresando en este
momento tras esta nueva llegada de usted
a Ucrania como como ve las cosas desde
la última vez ha empeorado a pues ha
mejorado un poco en algunas zonas Cuál
es el balance que usted te puede hacer
tras su llegada nuevamente a Ucrania
bueno Raúl la última vez que había
salido salía comienzos de agosto
obviamente pues hay una gran diferencia
entre un verano y un invierno obviamente
la situación ahora en cuanto a logística
y infraestructura es mucho más difícil
después de esos
múltiples ataques de las fuerzas rusas
contra la infraestructura energética
ucraniana obviamente tiene una misión
detrás Y es realmente hacer pasar a los
ucranianos tal vez el peor invierno de
su vida en un país que realmente tiene
unos inviernos bastante difíciles
encuentro que esto ha afectado y ha
cambiado otra vez la moral del país
tienen mucho miedo a lo que puedan ser
estos meses venideros obviamente hay una
gran satisfacción y una gran sentimiento
de Victoria por lo que ha pasado no
solamente por lo que pasó la región de
que lograron hacer retroceder y expulsar
a las tropas rusas en esa región sino
también aquí en la ciudad de gersona
haber retomado el control de la ciudad
de gerson que es la única capital de
provincia que fue capturada por los
rusos eso es una gran Victoria y su gran
moral para los ucranianos pero realmente
Ellos saben que vienen unos meses muy
duros por delante y y pues imagínense lo
que puede ser Catalina ya para finalizar
no quiero dejar de lado lo que estaba
usted hablando los rusos o no están
lejos de la ciudad están a solamente
simplemente al cruzar el río digamos que
están a los alrededores de la ciudad de
gerson también hay artillería hay
ataques en esa ciudad nuevamente hay
temor de que los rusos vuelvan con una
digamos contra ofensiva Para volver a
recuperar la ciudad de jerson Catalina
pues no se habla mucho realmente
Pero existe existe
destruido las ciudades son Realmente no
quedó muy destruidas solamente los
perímetros y algunos lugares pero es una
ciudad que realmente comparada con otras
donde ha estado la guerra está en buenas
condiciones pero los pueblos alrededor
están destruidos y mucha gente que
estaba viendo a sus casas o a sus
locales a ver cómo habían quedado nos
decían en este momento no podemos
invertir porque no sabemos realmente qué
va a pasar Cómo va a seguir
desarrollándose la guerra ellos esperan
que los rusos puedan retroceder
muchísimo más de esta región llevarlos a
bueno o expulsarlos del país que es lo
que realmente pretende Ucrania para
ellos tener la seguridad de que pueden
invertir otra vez en en esta
infraestructura Aunque hay un detalle
para terminar quiero decirle una cosa
que impresiona mucho de los ucranianos
es Cada vez que cae un misil hay una
destrucción en una casa y ellos viven
ahí
inmediatamente tapan el techo cambian la
ventana ha sido también como actos de
resistencia que hemos visto no solamente
en esta área sino en el resto del país